[Music]
40 finalists 20 winners $100,000 to drop
out of school and pursuing our dreams
this is teen technorati my name is Lucy
Guo and today my faith is gonna be
decided by Lego the finalists got an
hour and 45 minutes to build a Lego
bridge the span of the table first rule
is there's not many rules at all so we
wanted to see how they would work as a
team the question going through every
finalists mind at that point was what
exactly are we supposed to build in this
bridge that structural integrity going
down we know that there's going to be
some winner picked for the most creative
or most innovative bridge just like this
then we can actually bend and it's very
it's very exciting for these kids to
meet each other for the first time
sometimes they live in towns where
they're the only person who's
technically savvy and working on some
obscure technology and now here's a
roomful of 40 people who are just like
them so it's fun to see them interact
imagine this let's just say there's two
countries that actually drive on
different sides of the road so while
they drive across this bridge across the
border they then switch so they can
actually continue to drive right into
the other country you know cross border
transportation I've gotten to know
Darby pretty well she's really cool
to post then you slide the other one
through the to sway oh yeah I'm actually
competing for the title of Miss
Tennessee this June so I may be the
first chill fellow ever to compete in a
beauty contest I'm working on a product
called bambina and I'm tracking vital
signs in babies two years ago my very
close family friends lost a son to
sudden infant death syndrome I decided I
would use my ability to streamline
knowledge and topics together to build a
product I think I'm impressed by
everyone but right now Katherine Rey is
absolutely amazing probably the smartest
person I've ever met I started working
on my current project when I noticed how
difficult it was for my grandfather to
get up and out of his chair and sit back
down so I created prime a triple phase
wheelchair which is modular so that
every person can customize the
wheelchair to their specific personal
needs we're going to use a well known
truss structure to actually make it
structurally sound it's essential for a
scientist to foster their creative side
because innovation comes from looking at
things in ways that no one else does
I don't actually heard you guys talking
about nobody you mean the base would be
a hexagon you can go in that you could
go with that I just in looking for teal
fellas we do focus on people who have
unconventional ideas and those types of
people tend to be contrarian sometimes
that presents a challenge actually
working with people because they're
contrarians in all aspects of their
lives any time I saw an interesting
interaction between anyone I you know
made a mental note and in deliberations
those were discussing I suspect we're
actually being judged for how well we
get along and possibly our creative
problem-solving skills but that was on
the back of my mind I just not cool
Legos I'm a hundred percent of leader
and that's not even a question I make
people feel like there's so much more
out there and they can become their own
leaders just by following me for just a
little bit towards the end a leader
emerges in the successful teams and in
the unsuccessful teams everybody's still
running around and then you run out of
time
I'm not sure I mean I think we're
building two bridges I think ours was
the latter case the five of us were
running in five different directions
trying to build stuff I would build a
base and somebody else would build a
buttress and we'd have no way of
connecting them to be honest it was kind
of a mess when you have a team if you
design something too intricate you'll
never get it done in time all the
bridges blew our minds dirty we kind of
built a rocket him and built a bridge
around it we filled up tank losses of
water and look it's still holding this
is a mechanically sound drawbridge made
of Legos we faced it around the
beautiful geometry that is minimalistic
of hexagons our bridges called DNA kind
of a meta solution to international
travel like your challenge is really fun
we actually want so yeah we got a little
Lego set a surprise I gave it to my
roommate because she's never played with
Legos before we did not win but we were
able to build signed up I thought was
pretty good but the Lego challenge was
just a warm-up for the weekends main
event the Lightning now so be sure to
subscribe to the wire channel for the
next episode as my fellow teen
Technorati and I think our biggest
challenge stage fight
[Music]